Now we would have the open question and
answer session. We would request you to
kindly maintain the peaceful and calm
atmosphere. Dr. Zakir will be answering
your questions. We would like everyone
to know there's an estimated more than
100,000 people collected here. I think
more than 75% are Muslims. Are they
peaceful or not? Are they disciplined or
not?
You pick up one or two people as
terrorists, you cannot present them
examples. This is an example for the
people of India, for the people of the
world watching on peace TV. See, we are
so well
disciplined and we can analyze our
topics and debate our topics critically,
realistically and we also have open
question and answer forums. As now we
start with the open question answer
session in which you are welcome to ask
any question on the
topic is peace or is Islam the solution
for humanity. We have three microphones
arranged on the grounds. One next to the
stage on my left and one on my left in
the rare section for the brothers and we
have one microphone in the rare section
arranged for the sisters. The ladies can
put forward the question from that
microphone. Your question has to be on
the topic. It must be brief and to the
point. This is question time for you not
a lecture time. Please note you may ask
only one question at a time and then go
back at the queue and await your second
chance. As Dr. Zakir had just mentioned,
we will allow
non-Muslims first preference. They would
have preference over Muslim brothers to
put forward their question and they can
move ahead in the queue. The volunteers
would help you to come in the front
ahead of the Muslim brothers or sister
and put forward your question. I would
request a non-Muslim brothers and
sisters feel free, feel safe. We are
your brothers and sisters in analyzing
this topic. We are your protectors. We
are your custodians for this lecture in
a very peaceful
manner. May we have the first question
from the ladies section. The sisters
will give them a first chance and you
may kindly state your name and
profession before putting forward your
question so that Dr. Zakir can give an
more appropriate and relevant response.
Yes, sister. I'm Mrs. Bhavna
Ansari. So kindly please bear with me
and please excuse me humbly and
peacefully. I have been born in a Jen
society living in a Hindu society,
educated in a pure convent and married a
Muslim.
I have married as per the Indian
marriage
act and I'm staunchly eagerly waiting to
accept Islam as my
wholehearted
religion but please my brothers and
sisters what you preached what you said
about Islam I'm very thankful ful to you
for enlightening me. I am really reborn
today. But what you preach and what you
say and what is in
Islam, excuse me, I don't find people
practicing that
wholeheartedly. They are not attracting
me. Can you please give me a solution?
Because when you speak of fundamentalism
in Islam, it is positive. When you speak
of uh intolerance, it's positive. But in
practice, I don't find. So can you
please guide me? Sister has asked her a
good question. First of all like to
congratulate her and I welcome her and
as she say she's reborn the right word
in Islam is
revert because according to our beloved
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam every child is born in he's
born as a Muslim Muslim means a person
who submits his will to almighty god
every human being initially when he's
born he submits his will to almighty god
later on the prophet said that he's
influenced by the parents by the elders
by the teachers then he may become a
fire worshipper may go on the wrong
track. So therefore when a person comes
back to the original faith to din the
right word is not convert not reborn it
is revert. So sister I welcome you back
to this faith of peace and submitting
your will to almighty god. As far
question is
concerned that you have heard the
lectures and you agree with the points
you have read about Islam but your one
objection is
that Muslims or most of the Muslims
according to you they are not following
the teachings what is the
solution sister I do agree with you I do
agree with you that many don't follow
but according into statistics the
religion which is the maximum followed
I'm not talking in numbers if you count
the heads those who profess a religion
number one would be Christianity
somewhere close to 2
billion Islam 1.3 billion to 1.4 4
billion
but the percentage which practices and
follows the religion maximum is Islam
number one
maximum but yet I do agree with
you that in terms of numbers because 1.3
billion followers even if it be a small
percentage the numbers will run in
millions of Muslims don't follow the
religion therefore sister to understand
Islam Don't look at Muslims, please. And
I always say to understand a religion,
don't look at the followers of the
religion, but look at the authentic
sources. Please don't look at me. Don't
look at the Muslims around you. And I
gave you the example of the car and the
driver. If you want to know how good the
car is and if a person who does not know
how to drive sits behind the steering
wheel and he has an accident, he bangs
up the car. Who will you blame? The car
or the driver? You'll blame the driver.
So please don't understand Islam by
looking at the Muslims. That's the
reason we are giving this lectures for
both Muslims and non-Muslims
alike. Those Muslims who have
shortcomings, we are trying to get them
closer to the truth because they may be
namesake Muslims. We are trying to make
them practicing Muslim. At the same
time, we are delivering the message of
Islam to the non-Muslims also so that
you understand this religion. And though
you were born you were born in a Jan
family and you had non-Muslim around you
you're married to a Muslim but today
maybe after hearing the lecture and
after learning about Islam you have come
back to the faith and as you said that
previously maybe only for the sake of
name you may have adopted the surname
Ansari but today you have come back to
this true faith and we
congratul if you want to look at a
Muslim to understand Islam the best
example people is the last and final
messenger prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him. This book the Quran and the sayings
of the prophet have the solution for the
problems of humanity. Don't look at the
Muslims. Some Muslims may be close to
Islam. Some may be far away from Islam.
So look at the main source. Understand
it. Follow it. Inshallah get peace in
this world as well as hereafter.
Inshallah. Thank you very much. Thank
you sister for your question. Yes
brother. Sir my name is professor siti.
I am a engineer by profession and I'm
into a teaching profession. By God grace
I'm very strong in my maths. Uh to start
with I appreciate your hard work and
pray to God to give you double your age.
God has alerted you and I thank all the
Muslims here for giving me first
priority to ask my question. Sir, I've
gone through Bhagat Gita. I've gone
through Ramay and being Hindu. I was
after temples and everything but my
brother-in-law is a Muslim. He gave me
Quran. I've gone through it twice and I
can say in open I am following your
Quran very strictly. I have converted
your namas into English in the name of
God. The most gracious and the most
merciful, the creator, cherisher,
sustainer of the worlds, the master of
the day of judgment. I'm reading it 12
times, 15 times, 20 times. I don't see
timings. I just stand and pray to God
and I'm very satisfied with that. The
only one question I'm not getting it my
source of income being very strong in
maths. I am also a technical analyst
with stock market. I am very strong with
FNO market future and option. I don't
know how many people understand the
stock market here with a very
intellectual mathematics and very
intellectual playing the game. I am
always secure and always in profit after
the end of the month. It's a mathematic
game which people don't understand. Is
it okay to go ahead with such income?
I'm suffering from this last three
years. I'm I'm I'm earning money. I can
earn money whatever level I want to
earn. But I'm very I don't want to earn
anything wrong. If it is wrong, I will
leave that forever and I will go into
teaching profession forever.
Alhamdulillah. Because as a very good
question and I appreciate that after
reading the Bhagat Gita, Ramayan and the
Hindu scriptures, he read the Quran
twice and he agrees with it. He has a
brother-in-law who's a Muslim and he's
very strong in maths and even I happen
to be strong in
maths and in school days right from
standard one to
standard 9 10 I always back the price
without saying so mindboggling memory
I've never seen person like you go if
God grace I will be at at your place
forever if the
god inshallah inshallah
[Applause]
First I'll come to the question and then
inshallah I'll reply to his last
comment. As far question is concerned
that you are in the stock market about
futures and options etc. And you are so
good in maths and analyzing that always
at the end of the month you make a
profit. So question is that is this
earning halal or haram? As far as the
stock market is concerned, stock per se
is not haram per se. As long as the
stocks you deal in, it is according to
the guidelines of Islam. What is haram
in Islam is ribba. It's interest. There
are many verses in the Quran is in eight
different places. Almighty God says in
the Quran that Rabbi is haram. In surah
Iran chapter number 3 verse number 130.
In surah is chapter 4 verse 161. In
surah bakar chapter 2 verse number 275
thrice. In surah bakar chapter 2 verse
276. As well as in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 278 it says that give up
your demands of ribba of interest of
user and those who do not give up the
demands of ribba and usuzer verse number
279 Allah says take notice of from Allah
and his rasool Allah and his messenger
so dealing in interest is haram but
share market is somewhat following the
principles of Islam of profit and loss
sharing share per se instead of taking a
loan from the bank, we make partners
because the banking system makes a rich
person more rich, poor person more poor.
It encourages things evil in society
like in 80s the banks fund gambling
dens, alcohol bars and Islamic system is
different. Islamic banking is
different. So Islam encourages profit
and loss sharing. In the stock market,
what do you do that you buy a share? So
you become a partner in that company
whether 1%
10%.1% 01%. So being partner in profit
and loss sharing is encouraged in Islam.
So if you're dealing in stock market and
shares as long as it is within the
purview of the Islamic Sharia as long as
you do not buy shares of a company which
deals in
alcohol company which deals in interest
financial companies whether it be banks
whether financial instrument companies
company which deals in media obsinity
pornography. So all the evils of society
if the company you invest in is not
investing in the evil of society
alcoholism or drugs or drug
pharmaceutical companies allowed drugs
means cocaine and brown sugar or we
living with obscinity it may be film
industry so if you buy shares of these
companies it's haram. Secondly, if you
involved in
speculation that is gambling, you know
you being in the stock market. People
buy now after 2 minutes again they sell
because of prior information or because
of you know so gambling is prohibited in
Islam. So if your stock market is good,
you want to invest in it, you want to
stay for good, be a partner, make and
even I'm involved in stock market and so
you're not replying to the right point.
I'm asking it is futures and options. It
is put in a call. I'm coming to it. You
can just pay 10 rupees and buy stocks
for 100 rupees and you keep it for years
and years together. I'm coming to it.
Yes sir. I like giving holistic reply
rather than Okay. Thanks a lot sir.
Sorry for disturbing. Now coming to the
futures option that you buy part of the
shares and you deal within etc.
talking about futures if you pay part
and have it with you I know you can sell
then you can have security on that then
there's another person which the
derivatives which can even I know about
this I may not be an expert like you but
I mean this
is so dealing in futures it's not
permitted it's
not margin trading in certain thing like
real estate you buy 10% of that and then
increases because you have to make
timely payment. If you buy a flat
suppose the payment time is 2 years, you
pay 10% now, 20% later, the rates go up,
you sell. That's fine. But in shares, it
doesn't work like that. In futures, it
doesn't work like that. So, because you
don't possess in your hands, you have
paid part of the money and then someone
else backs you up that if it goes down,
then they hedge it. You know, hedging,
they hedge it. So, all these things are
not permitted in Islam. But pure stock
as long as the thing which you deal in
if it is Islamic it's allowed and you
ask me the question that all these
things that you get you get a large
money income if it's not allowed you
don't like it see the money that you
earn as you said if it's not permitted
you stop it so what we interested we are
interested in peace in this world and
the akar the peace in the next world is
longer peace so if you are earning the
halal inshallah you'll get good in this
world as well as in the and I pray to
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala for your peace
and success in this world as well as in
the in the next world hope. Thanks Lord.
Thanks for appreciate for giving me so
much of time and definitely I will be
following it strictly sir. Thank you.
Yes
brother. My name is Abishek. When I was
14 I ran from my home fighting my
family. A man from Saudi take me to
Kerala. Uh he teach me
Islam. Two years before I accepted
Islam. Now also I am accepting in Islam
in front of all
ashanillah. Asha Muhammad and Abdu.
Your questions
brother any question you have for Dr.
Zakir? No sir Dr. Zak would like to
comment on that. Dear brother I welcome
you and I congratulate you religion of
peace and surely you can testify that no
sword was used by that Saudi. Did he use
any sword on you brother? No. Any force?
No. Any gun? No. I accepted from my
heart. Masha otherwise IB will question
me.
I would like to give you a translation
of the Quran if you can come on the
stage because I remember the first time
I give a talk 8 days back there was a
sister there who accepted Islam. Believe
me I can't see the face. I can only see
the face of the questioner who's on my
left on the first mic. I can't see your
face. I can't see the face of the lady
who accepted on the first day on
Saturday. I became questioning the
intelligence that where is that lady? I
said I don't even know her face. Maybe
on the television you saw her. The
gathering is so vast. So surely the
people on the television see your face.
I haven't seen your face. So you can
testify to the people that there was no
force used on you and no one can use
force on you to accept Islam. If you
like it with your heart and this country
of ours, this country India is one of
the few countries in the world in whose
constitution is mentioned that every
citizen of India has the right to
preach, practice and propagate his
religion. It is a democratic country but
I'm proud of this country that we have
the right to preach, practice and
propagate religion. Forcing anyone to
accept any religion is prohibited is not
only prohibited in the Indian government
law. It is prohibited even in Islam. You
can't force anyone to accept the
religion of Islam. You deliver the
message if he accepts good. If he
doesn't accept also no
problem because he can at least testify
to almighty God on day of judgment that
we delivered the message of peace to
you. Thank you brother for accepting the
religion of peace. Thank you very much.
Yeah. Any sister on the mic? Um good
evening sir. I'm Dr. Puja. I'm a
physotherapist. Uh sir, during your
oration, you uh just uh said these
lines. I would just like to repeat them.
Uh you said every person who is an
extremist Muslim, the problems of the
humanity will be solved. I would just
like to make a correction. I'm too young
to correct you. Sorry for that. But uh
from the core of my heart, I believe
this sentence would have been more
authentic if he put it this way. Every
person who is an extremist, the problems
of the humanity will be solved.
Messoever he is a Muslim, a Hindu, a
Christian, whosoever.
Dr. Puja has asked a very good question
and sister if I'm wrong, I'm ready to
accept the mistake. The question answer
is meant for that. If I say by mistake 2
+ 2 is equal to 5, you have a right to
correct me. It's not five, it's four.
I'm a human being. I'm not a human
computer. I'm a human being. I can make
mistakes. That's the reason we have open
question answeration. But coming to your
comment, I said that if everyone would
have an extremist, Muslims, the problem
would have solved and you corrected me
by saying that if we would have said
that every human being would have been
an extremist, the problem would have
solved. Extremist in which way? An
extremist. The way you said extremist.
The way you said to be extremely kind,
extremely loveful. Sister, if you heard
my talk, I said an extremist Muslim is a
person who's extremely kind, extremely
merciful, extremely loving, extremely
honest, extremely just. Otherwise, there
can be an extremist robber who wants to
rob. There can be an extremist rapist.
So, if I just say extremist the problem
solve, the rapist will be happy with me.
They say I'm an extremist rapist, you
know. So sister, if you translate the
full into English, you'll understand
more correctly. What I meant was that if
every human being becomes an extremist
Muslim means if every human being
becomes an extremist peaceful person
submitting his will to God, then the
problems of humanity will be solved. Now
because I use the Arabic word, it does
not go down the throats of many people.
I'm not talking about you, sister. No,
no, no. I'm talking about the media.
when I say Islam Muslim it doesn't go
down the throat. So I would like to
rephrase the question for the benefit of
the non-Muslims. If every human being
becomes an extremely peaceful person
submitting his will to almighty god the
problems of humanity will be solved.
Maysoever he is Muslim, Hindu or
Christian. Now if you add mayo soever is
Hindu Muslim Christian rapist robber
then the formula doesn't work sister
because if you say mayoever be a Muslim
if he submits his will to almighty God
he has to be a Muslim and if a Hindu
submits to God he is notable by God. Not
like that. Yes sister wait let me you
ask a second question I give a second
answer. No you are perfectly right. What
is the definition of the word Hindu
sister? Hindu is a geographical
definition meaning those people living
in the land of India. In that definition
I'm a Hindu sister. I'm a Hindu Muslim
by geographical
definition. But this word Hindu was
first used by the Arabs when they came
to India. When I go to Saudi Arabia they
say Hindi Hindi Hindu you know. So this
Hindu actually is a geographical
definition but today it is used as a
misnomer to describe as a religion.
According to Swami Viveanandanda he says
that the followers should actually be
called as Vantist because they follow
the Vedas. So Hindu is a misnomer. You
ask any scholar. So if you say can a
Hindu be a Muslim geographical
definition I am a Hindu. I'm living in
India. I submit my will to God. I'm a
peaceful person but everyone but but
sister even the Americans can be good
even the English can be good if I say
everyone in the world should live in
India as it is there is population as it
is there are more than 1 million people
reframe my question sister please let me
complete the answer you asked a question
I'm giving the answer you asked a
question I'm giving the answer we'll
give you a second chance no problem
sister but at least let me clarify
therefore the words that you use you
should understand the meaning of the
word If every human being should live in
India then the Indian government will
have a problem. As it is they
say they're talking about family
planning we two and our
two mean after one let there be a gap
after two you should not at all produce
family planning you can hear my answer
in Quran modern science. So sister
therefore the words that you speak if
it's not in English people sometime have
confusion. So if you are a Hindu
submitting a will to God submitting and
following the Vedas. If you see my talk
sister on similarities between Islam and
Hinduism the Vedas say that you should
believe in one God. If you follow the
Vedas it's mentioned in Upanishad.
Chandoga of Panishad chapter number six
section number two verse number one. It
says
that God is only one without a second.
It's mentioned in the Veda chapter
number 32 verse number
three of that God there is no pratima.
Pratima means image, statue, sculpture,
photograph of that almighty god.
According to Veda there are no images,
there are no photographs, there are no
sculptures, there are no statues. If
you're such a Hindu, it's mentioned in
the Veda of another messenger to come.
The final messenger whose name is
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. He
is prophesized in the Kyotar chapter
number two, verse number five, verse
number seven, verse number 9, verse
number 11, verse number 15 that this
Kyotar he'll be born in the city of
peace that is Makkah. His father's name
shall be Vishnu Yash, servant of God,
translated Abdullah, which was the name
of the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sad. His mother's name
shall be sumati mean peaceful serenity
in Arabic it's amina which was the name
of prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
mother he will be born on 12th month of
madav we know he was born on 12th of baw
he have four companions the first for
rashadin I can go on and on and on given
a lecture on similarities between Islam
and Hinduism what I say sister that let
us agree that at least one book is the
word of god Hindus will say that the
veda is the word of god Christians will
say bible is the word of God. Muslim
will say Quran is the word of God. Let
us at least agree to follow what is
common in the
scriptures. Come to common terms as we
now what is not common sister let's not
fight on that. We'll discuss that
tomorrow. Fine. So let us agree all the
religious scriptures all the major
scriptures whether it be the Bible
whether it be the Veda whether it be the
Quran whether it be the pari scriptures
whether it be the six scriptures they
say you have to believe in one god. Most
of the major religions they prophesize
the coming of the last and final
messenger. It's mentioned even in the
Bible in Deuteronomy chapter number 18
verse number 18. Book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 18 verse number 19. In
the book of Isaiah chapter number 29
verse number 12 it's prophesied in the
song of Solomon chapter number 5 verse
number 16. In the New Testament Gospel
of John chapter number 14 verse number
16 in the Gospel of John chapter number
15 verse number 26. In the Gospel of
John chapter number 16 verse number 7.
In the gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 12- 14 Jesus Christ peace
be upon him says I have many things to
say unto you but he cannot bear them now
for he when the spirit of truth shall
come he shall guide you into all truth
he shall not speak of himself all that
he shall he speak so what we come to
know from all these major scriptures
that you have to believe in one god who
has got no images who has got no ideals
you have to believe in the last and
final messenger so let us agree sister
let's not fight on the differences let's
agree to follow what is common in the
Hindu scriptures
in the pari scriptures in the Christian
scriptures you're talking Hindu Muslim
I'm talking about parism I'm talking
about Islam let us agree to follow
what's common and inshallah all the
human beings who believe in God they'll
have to agree there's one god who has
got no images who has got no statues and
have to believe that one last and final
messenger has to come whose name is
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him then
we will have every human being should be
an extremely peaceful person submitting
his will to almighty god then the
problems of humanity will be solved.
Hope that answers the question sister.
Yeah. Thank you sir. We have brother
Abhishek who had just asked the previous
question. He's already at the back of
the stage and he doesn't want to miss
the opportunity to receive Quran from
Dr. Zakir. We allow him to accept it.
[Applause]
The brother came at the back of the
stage and he was requesting the
volunteers I would like to receive.
Alhamdulillah we said we accept it. Yes
brother. The next question
[Music]
for people of the book. People of the
group 25
and I want to ask other question also.
One minute you know
I I travel to let him answer the first
question then we will allow you a second
one brother.
asked the question he says and I know
Mah by he's been coming to IRF since
1991 and he takes more video cassettes
from IRF even than the Muslims. So his
list in IRF taking maximum number of
video cassettes literature etc. Mah
asked the question that as the earlier
scriptures as the Quran says Torah
Zabur revealed to Moses David Jesus
Christ peace be upon them that the
Muslims say it has changed so in the
Quran when the Quran speaks about the
Jews that oh people of the book Jews and
Christians so when it speaks about in
such a way so isn't the Quran also
written by the human beings correct your
argument is that how does Does it speak
about the Jews and Christians? Whether
if you had come for my earlier talk is
the Quran God's word. Were you there for
the talk? No, I I was not. That talk
dealt with this topic in detail. I don't
intend repeating the full talk and it
dealt in details that how people al
prophet Muhammad wrote it being a human
being for what reason for power for gain
etc. and a 2 hours lecture which I can't
repeat but coming to your main question
that because it says that oh people of
the
book it's telling so that means it
indicates written by a human being
whether if you analyze in the Quran as
you rightly said that there are 25
messengers mentioned by name and most of
the messengers mentioned of almighty god
they are Jewish and if you see these
names also mentioned in the bible about
more than onethird of the Quran is
addressed to the Jews Why giving
examples that Almighty God did favors to
the people of Israel? Yan Israel, don't
you know the favors we did to you, but
you did so and so, so and so thing. So
these are examples given in the Quran by
Almighty God that there were prophets
who came earlier to these people. Some
people rejected the prophet, some people
accepted the prophet. So when it is
giving an
example it
says say oh people of the
book come to come in terms has been
assen you. So the Quran is telling us
Muslims that you have to speak to the
people of the book. People of the book
means people of the revelation
indicating in this Quran specifically
when the word people of the book is used
it is referring to Yahoud and Nasara to
the Jews and the Christians. So Allah is
telling the Muslims to talk to
the Allah also says oh people of the
book. So that means Quran is addressing
not only to the Muslims or to the Arabs
but to the also. Therefore I mentioned
that this last and final revelation the
glorious Quran was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs. It was sent for
the whole of humanity. If it was a human
work, if it was a human work as you say
then almighty God will never mention
that go and ask the Jews and Christians.
It is mentioned in the scriptures. At
that time there were many who did not
know about the Jews and Christians what
happened in the past. When they checked
up it turned out to be true. Further it
says it talks even about prophecies that
what's going to happen in the future. So
all these things brother it cannot be
the work of a human being. For more
details, you can refer to my talk is the
Quran God's word. Hope that answers the
question. Uh one, you know, I travel
more than 55 countries and Quran and
Hadith, they prohibit the idol worship.
But you go you other religion
Christianity uh this one u Buddhism and
Chinese religion Jinism all other
religion they have idol worship and you
know Muslim maybe they are 15 to 20% in
this world
total percentage wise so other people
are wrong you know Christian one minute
uh any Anglican church or Russian
Orthodox or Greek Orthodox or Catholic
or Protestants you know Chinese they
have the big statue of the god so all
all they are wrong brother asked a very
good question he's saying the Muslims
approximately 15 20% some say 25%
whatever it is you say 15% 20% I've got
no problem so he's telling that
Christians they do idol worship fine I
agree with you he says that Buddhism
create big statue what do you think
they're wrong brother the majority
doesn't win in Islam in Islam The truth
prevails. The majority people a couple
of hundred years ago said the world was
flat.
Majority do you know that majority of
the people few hundred years back said
the world is flat. Is the world flat by
the
mah? So majority people can be wrong in
Islam. Allah says in the Quran in surah
Isra chapter number 17 verse number
81 say that truth has arrived and
falsehood perish for falsehood is by its
nature bound to perish. Therefore in
Islam majority never wins if you go to
America in America pornography is
legalized. Do you believe in
pornography? No. So many go to European
countries. No. No. Do you believe in
pornography with the I don't believe.
Very good. Very good human being. I
congratulate you. But the majority
people in western world believe in
pornography. So will you believe in
pornography? Will you see pornography?
Very good boy. See you are close to the
truth. So majority never wins. As far as
you say in Christianity, idol worship is
there. In Christianity idol worship is
not there. Christians do idol worship.
Like some Muslims do wrong things. If
you read the Christian Bible, which you
have read the Christian Bible, I'm sure
it's mentioned in the Bible in the book
of Deuteronomy chapter number
five verse number 7 8 and 9. Thou shalt
not have any graven image of me,
Almighty God. He's telling in the Old
Testament, "Thou shalt have no graven
image of me, of anything, of any
likeness in the heaven above, in the
earth beneath, and the water beneath the
earth. Thou shalt not serve them." Now
bow onto them for I thy God, thy lord is
a jealous God. Same message repeated in
the book of
Exodus chapter number 20 verse number
3-5 that thou shalt have no graven image
of me of anything of any likeness in the
heaven above in the earth beneath and
the water beneath the earth. Thou shalt
not bow onto them nor serve them for I
thy God thy lord is a jealous God. So
according to the old testament idol
worship is prohibited. And Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said it's mentioned in
the gospel of Matthew chapter number 5
verse number 7-20. Think not that I have
come to destroy the law of the prophets.
I have come not to destroy but to
fulfill. Whosoever shall break one of
the least
commandments and teach me to do so shall
be called least in the kingdom of
heaven. And whosoever shall keep the
commandment shall be called great in the
kingdom of heaven. Unless your
righteousness exceeds the righteousness
of the scribes and the Pharisees, in no
way shall you enter the kingdom of
heaven. That means if you want to enter
the kingdom of heaven according to Jesus
Christ peace be upon him you have to
follow each and every law of the old
testament of Moses peace be upon him no
making images of almighty god yet they
make why all the Christian don't make
the protestant don't make your knowledge
of Christians is a bit less you're a
student
yet the Catholics they make they make a
statue that's the reason the protestant
they protest what you're doing is wrong
so according to the bible you should not
make images of almighty god I agree with
you. Most of the Hindus they do idly
worship and I quoted
earlier of that god there is no pratima
there are no images there are no
sculptures there are no statues brother
do you do idle worship I am doing no ah
but you're not following the veda
because I believe in all religion all I
believe all the whe you know god knows
because you know god knows this all
religion whether if you are believing in
all the religions that means
irrespective whether you are following
other religion or not you're not
following Hinduism. Brother, you are not
following Hinduism. What I'm telling
you, God is sleeping now. He knows
everything. He created all the earth and
heaven. So he knows every religion have
their own place like Islam. Brother,
let's ask one question at a time.
There's a big cue there. I will answer
your next question. After that, go
behind the queue. You are most welcome
to ask your fine. You ask that is God
sleeping? Allah gives this answer in the
Quran in surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 255. Allah says,
that Allah is eternal, absolute. He's
self-subsisting. He does not require to
sleep. No slumber can seize him. Nor
does he require rest. You and I require
to sleep. You and I require rest. God
does not require to sleep. Allah clearly
says in the Quran, if he wanted, he
could have made each and every human
being except Islam submit to the will.
If you wanted very easy just but this is
a test for the hereafter. God is testing
you. God is testing me. If God wants, he
can easily make you not do idly worship.
But where is the test? The test is God
has given you the rules. Now, do you
follow the rule or not? You say, "Do you
follow all the religions, you're not
following Hinduism, you're not following
Islam, you're not following
Christianity, you're not following
Sikism, you're not following Buddhism.
Buddhism quote me any reference from
Dhapad, from any Buddhist scriptures
where Buddha said, "Make a statue of
me." He never said
that. Where did he say
that? Tomorrow suppose tomorrow if any
Muslim makes a statue of prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him if he makes a
statue and calls a Muslim I say he's
wrong. The prophet never said I make a
statue of him. So just because someone
diverts and does the wrong thing whether
he's in minority or majority that does
not become the truth. Buddha never said
make a statue of him. So if someone is
against the Buddhist sculptures, they're
helping the Buddhist follow the
religion. So just because they made a
big statue of Buddha, that does not mean
they're following Buddha. Therefore, I
said if you want to understand religion,
don't look at followers. Brother Mah,
don't look at me. Look at the
scriptures, look at the Quran, read the
Quran, read the Veda. At least what is
common follow. What is not common? Keep
it aside. If you say you follow all the
religions, you're not following
Hinduism, you're not following
Christianity, you're not following
Islam, leave aside all, I am requesting
you at least follow what is common. What
is not common, you can discuss later on.
You are not even following what is
common. Leave aside following all the
religions. So the day you stop doing
idol worship, then I can say at least
you're following one major part of all
the religions. the day you believe in
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him as
the last messenger then I can say you
are following the two major pillars in
most of the major religions hope that
answers the question okay thank you
thank you brother can we have the next
question is there a brother the
non-Muslim
yeah good evening doctor my name is J
Majit here I have completed my
engineering this year and first of all
uh this is my first time I've been
visiting your open talk and it was
really appreciate able the knowledge of
all the scripts you have and the
confidence you have and lot of Muslim
supporters which really follow you. Now
my question to you is a bit political.
Now I would like to ask you doctor uh do
you advise all the Muslims to follow the
principles of Mahatma
Gandhi like example of nonviolent
satyagraha which he fought for us to get
an independence from Britishers. uh as I
believe and I respect all the holy books
like uh Quran, Gita, Bible. Apart from
that in today's world, I feel I am more
an Indian. So would you advise Muslims
to follow principles of Mahatma Gandhi
like nonviolence, satyagra or any of the
principles of Mahatma Gandhi?
has a question that do I suggest the
Muslims to follow the principles of
Mahatma Gandhi then he change it to any
principle of Mahatma Gandhi that is
nonviolence and satyagra whichever sorry
sorry to interrupt doctor or any of the
principles of Mahatma Gandhi I I got
your question starting you said the
principles meaning all the principles
then you said any principle I'll give
answer to
both all those principles of Mahatma
Gandhi which match with the Quran which
match with our creator matched with the
saying of prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam I've got no objection
telling the Muslims follow it
wholesale for example the satyagra
movement of Mahatma Gandhi nonviolence
the prophet did the same not that he
copied from Mahatma Gandhi it is Mahatma
Gandhi who copied from the prophet which
I'll come to it later
on if you see the maki age of the
prophet the first approximate 13 years
that is spent in Makkah
He told the followers, "No violence."
Many non-Muslims accepted Islam. They
were fierce warriors. The prophet said,
"Your jihad is sabar." Sabar means
patience. Many Muslims were killed and
butchered. The pagan makkins that time
they targeted the weak Muslims. They
tortured them. They killed them. So
those who were powerful, they got angry.
They said that they killed our brothers.
We will take revenge. The prophet said
your jihad is
sabar. See someone who has the power to
fight
back and he fights back it's good but
someone who has the power to fight back
and the commandment is don't fight back
and then he restrains himself that is
real jihad. Jihad in Arabic means to
struggle. It means to strive. So here
the prophet's commandment was
nonviolence.
They went on the streets only saying
that we bear witness that there's no god
but Allah and prophet Muhammad peace be
the messenger of Allah. People stoned
them they did not retaliate. People
abused them they did not retaliate. The
prophet went to people stoned him. He
didn't
retaliate. So this is one of the
strategies but not the only
strategy. So do you want to complete the
answer? No. So after after Dr. Zakar
completes the question we'll allow you
to ask. You have to have some patience
brother. Okay. Okay sir. You have asked
a question I have to give the reply. So
this part of Mahatma Gandhi of
nonviolence depending on situation. But
now if you tell the Indian government
you know the person is robbing
nonviolence don't arrest him. The person
is raping nonviolence don't arrest him.
The Indian government will agree. Every
country has a police force. This force
is meant to let peace prevail in that
country. So sometimes they use force
against the criminal to let priest
prevail. You can't tell the government
can't tell the police commissioner of
Bombay that see Mahatma Gandhi said
nonviolence. So a person is robbing let
him rob only do shika but don't rob.
Suppose they come and rape your sister
he'll say okay don't rape don't rape.
Nonviolence. So nonviolence is the
best. In
Islam there is something like zul. Zul
in Arabic the best translation or zul
can be
operation. And a person who does
operation is called as a zim. Zalem
person. And who is more zim than a
person who can stop the operation and
does not stop the operation.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said in the hadith of Sai Muslim that if
you see an evil you stop it with your
hand. If you cannot stop it with the
hand then stop it with the tongue. If
you cannot stop it with the tongue then
curse in your heart. And if you curse in
your heart you are the lowest level of
M. You are the lowest level of
Muslim. Suppose you see a rape taking
place. Mahatma Gandhi said oh don't drip
don't drip. The best is if you have the
power to stop, stop it with your hand.
She may not be your sister. She may not
be your mother. If you see someone
raping, if you can stop it with your
hand, you stop it with your hand. If you
cannot, if you're weak, if you don't
have the power, at least say, "Oh,
rape. Dear brother, don't rape." At
least with your tongue. If you think if
I say with my tongue also he'll kill me,
at least curse in your heart. So
depending upon the situation the
strategy keeps on changing. When prophet
went to
Medina there he was peaceful he did
surah he signed a contract between the
pagan unbeliever and Muslim they broke
the contract when they come for war then
the almighty god said when they come for
war don't get scared fight kill them. So
depending upon the situation and
according to the people historians
Michael Hart he wrote a book of the 100
most influential people in human history
number one he gave to prophet Muhammad
peace be upon
him but I'm not mentioning him for that
among the important misses was Mahatma
Gandhi Michael a famous historian after
mentioning the 100 most influential
people in history he mentioned the
important misses and in that he
mentioned Mahatma Gandhi and he says the
satra movement of Mahatma Gandhi which
was one of the important movements which
let the Britishers go back but what he
said even if this movement wasn't there
yet India would have got independence
according to the famous
historian
Michaelart so what we realize that
depending upon the situation we have to
use the strategy you can't say always
nonviolence sometimes times violence
will have to be used to let peace
prevail like how you have police in
every country in every state. So anyone
who goes beyond the limits, who rapes,
who robs, who harms other people that
time as a last resort like the country
says the police can use force.
Similarly, Islam says as a last resort,
as a last alternative, sometimes force
can be used to let peace prevail. Hope
that answers the question. If any other
question, you're most welcome, brother.
No sir, I'm convinced with it and thanks
for the that's the reason I said don't
interrupt me. Alhamdulillah. It's my
profession. I'm in the field. If I give
the complete answer, people are
convinced. I start the answer, people
want to object. When you are putting
your hand up, your mind is going on the
question. You aren't paying attention on
my answer. So when you listen with an
open mind, inshallah, I will answer your
question. If not, inshallah, I will give
you a second opportunity. Okay? And I
would also like to advise all the Muslim
people over here, you have a great
scholar like Dr. Nyak. So please follow
Muslims 100% as uh there are some doubts
like people do not follow it 100%. So I
hope all the Muslims will follow the
Muslim religion 100% and make India
proud. Thank you. Thank you very much
brother. I would request that all the
Muslims should follow Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and the last and final
revelation the glorious Quran. As far as
the brother, he said that Muslims should
follow me 100%. I request him that even
he should follow me at least what I
speak about the Quran and the say
hadith. So brother we are waiting for an
opportunity. I want you also to follow
me as long as I match with the Quran and
say if I don't match with Quran and say
even Dr. Zak is zero. Zak has got no
value. What I say if it matches with the
last and final commandment the glorious
Quran and last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. You
follow me. I request you even you should
follow me what I speak about the Quran.
This say had
yes sister the next
question. This is Bhages s. I'm a
non-Muslim. I want to accept Islam in
front of everybody because I want all
these people to view him on my sha on
the day of judgment.
sister. I think Dr. Zakir can pronounce
it properly and she can repeat. If I say
it and you can pronounce it, you can say
Allahallu. I bear witness I bear witness
that there's no god but Allah there's no
god but Allah and prophet Muhammad and
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him peace
be upon him is the servant and messenger
of almighty god is is the servant and
messenger of almighty god welcome to the
religion of peace
thank you
we find that in this 10 day conference
that we have this 10-day conference
there are many people who accepted Islam
and many questions were asked to several
of the speakers and they were convinced
that this is the only solution for
humanity and we appreciate that
sister and I pray to Allah subhananaa
tala to grant you ja peace in this world
and the next world inshallah any
question sister you're most welcome to
ask this non-Muslim sister she does not
want to disclose her identity. Welcome
you. Without disclosing her identity,
she can ask a question. She is a student
of MBM. She asks why is Allah referred
to Allah? Why not any other name?
The sister asked a question that why is
Allah referred to as Allah and why not
other names? The reply is given in the
Quran in surah Isra chapter number 17
verse number 110 where it's mentioned in
the Quran.
Say call upon him by Allah or call upon
him by whichever name you call upon him
to him belongs the most beautiful names.
You can call almighty God Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala by any name but it
should be a pure name. It should be a
correct name. It should be a name given
by himself. And there are no less than
99 attributes given in the glorious
Quran had alman ram al karim al-hakim
most merciful most compassionate most
wise no less than 99. And the crowning
one is Allah. And this message that to
Allah belongs the most beautiful name
besides surah surah chapter 17 verse
number 110. It's also repeated in surah
t chapter number 20 verse number 8 and
surah chapter number 7 verse number 180
and surah al hash chapter 59 verse
number 24 where Allah says that to him
belongs the most beautiful name but the
crowning name is Allah. Now why do we
Muslims prefer calling Allah by the
Arabic word Allah instead of the English
word God. The reason is sister all the
other names and words they can be played
around
with. For example, the English word God.
If you add s to God, it becomes God's
plural of God. There's nothing like
plural
Allah. Say Allah and only. If you add d
e ss to god, it becomes goddess, a
female god. In Islam, there's nothing
like male Allah or female Allah. Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala has got no gender.
If you add father to God, it becomes
godfather. He's my godfather. He's my
guardian. There's nothing like Allah aba
or Allah father in Islam. If you add a
mother to God, it becomes
godmother. There's nothing like Allah
mother or Allah in Islam. If you prefix
tin before God, it becomes tin god,
meaning a fake god. There's nothing like
tin Allah in Islam. That's the reason we
Muslims, we prefer calling Allah by the
Arabic word Allah. And that's the reason
this word Allah is also present in most
of the major religious scriptures. If
you read the six scriptures, one of the
attributes given to Almighty God is
Allah. If you read the Christian Bible
in the Gospel of Mark chapter number
15:34, in the Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 27 verse number 46, when Jesus
Christ peace be upon him, when he was
put on the cross, he cried
out. Oh God, oh God, why hast thou
forsaken me?
Does sound like, oh God, oh God, why has
thou forsaken me? No. But if you
translate into
Arabic, it says
Allah similar. So
Hebrew and Arabic, they are sister
languages. And if you read the Scoffield
dictionary, it pronounces Allah also Li
also as Allah. A L A H. Same. So Allah
is even mentioned in the Bible. Even in
the Hindu scriptures, it's mentioned in
the Vedas. There's a separate upanishad
by the name of Allah upanishad. So this
word Allah is also mentioned by name in
the major world religious scriptures.
This is the proper name of the true
almighty god. Hope that answers the
question.
Yes brother.
Hindu philosophy.
Hindu
philosophy, Hindu philosophy.
philosophy. Maybe
Quran.
Quran or
Islam.
for level.
The brother asked a very good important
question. He has said that in Hindu
philosophy we believe that the full
world, the whole humanity is like a
family and everyone should live happily
in this family, earn money, live happily
enjoy life. That was his question. Is it
similar in Islam? And he says surely in
Islam it will be somewhat similar. And
then he comes to his question and asks
that this Quran it should reach the full
world. Is there a mistake in the Muslims
expelling the Quran or is there a
mistake in the people understanding it
that today we find Muslims are being
labeled as terrorist as fundamentalist
as extremist. So what is the real
problem? As far as the first question, I
do agree with him that Hinduism does say
that the whole world is a family. We
should live happily, earn, enjoy. Islam
says somewhat similar except for the
ending. Allah says in the Quran injur
chapter number 49 verse number
13. Oh humankind, we have created you
from a single pair of male and female
and have divided you into nations and
tribes so that you may recognize each
other. Not that you may despise each
other. So the Quran says that all the
humankind has got one common grand great
great great great grandparents Adam and
Eve. May Allah be pleased with them
both. And Allah has divided us into
nations and tribes, different colors,
different languages, so that you may
recognize each other. And the criteria
for judgment in the sight of almighty
God, it's not wealth, it's not cast,
it's not color, it's not sex, but it is
tawa. And God Almighty said, "Most
honored." In the same verse of Surah
Jarat 49:13, Allah continues and says,
"And the most honored amongst you is the
person who has taka." In Hinduism he
said that we have to lead a life happily
earn. In Islam we have to lead your life
happily. Yes but on the basis of tawa.
The only criterion which makes you
superior. It is tawa. It is
righteousness. It is god consciousness.
It's not money. It's not wealth. It's
not sex. It's not car. Now coming to his
question that the Quran is such a good
book. Is it that there's problem in
communication regarding the preachings
of Quran or are we not able to
understand that's the reason brother we
having this talk Islam the solution in
humanity the problem is in media
portraying Islam and we Muslims it's our
fault I do agree with you we aren't
expert in media we Muslim to
blame as it is the duty of every Muslim
to convey the message of Islam to convey
the message of the Quran to the whole of
humanity. We aren't doing a full job. We
are trying. We trying a level best.
Today the best way you can reach the
masses. Now see the gathering surely
hundreds of thousand. I don't know how
many but yet for us it is retail.
100,000 is retail for me. We believe in
millions. Therefore we're showing live
on the satellite channel and there's
estimated viewership of more than 60
million people watching. 60 million the
100,000 200,000 is peanuts I can give
shahada to Allah subhana wa t'ala that
we have delivered the message to
humankind and 60 million is at least 1%
yet is nothing 1% of humankind if you
count it to be 6 billion what we want
that we Muslims should be more forward
in media there should be more channels
it should spread much more and I do
agree with you there is a problem in
understanding that the reason as you
mentioned that we are being labeled as
extremist as fundamentalist as terrorist
and my talk was based on that that how
should you reply when a person says that
you're a fundamentalist you're a
terrorist you're extremist so hopefully
inshallah you'll get the translation
after this lecture hopefully hope that
answers the question by